still ahead on this Monday Democrats are
ramping up their calls to impeach
President Trump let's go they're trying
to impeach me democratic congressman
brad Sherman has found an article of
impeachment
Charmian nobody at beaches me I think
we're gonna be hearing the word
impeachment a lot more often
Wow German you know congressman chairman
it's a white guy he's kind of a loser
Joey help me I don't want to get
impeached seola Sheila jackson-lee here
people want to impeach me you realize
that why probably because you're a
racist yeah but besides that there's
German German
oh there is German where Sherman yeah I
don't care
hello chairman you're going to impeach
me you tell you something I'm going to
impeach you I'm gonna make you feel like
Jets essence pellet of a puddle you
understand me
you think you're tough you're fired mr.
president you can't fire a member of
Congress that's stupid
sit down let's talk okay mr. president
would you get that a yard sale
no that probably goes back a hundred
years here in the House of
Representatives for a long time junk
okay
well mr. president first I'd like to
serve these papers on you Wylie thank
you that in person it's been referred to
the Judiciary Committee and if the whole
house votes in favor of those articles
you will be tried in the Senate for high
crimes and misdemeanors I can fire meat
loaf but I can't fire this guy gotta
find another way out of this how's this
I'll make a deal with you I'm one of the
great deal makers so what do you want
all I want is this letter of resignation
how's this what if I give you a cool
name like the bradster we're like sure
man okay man instead of Sherman how
about like Brad Lee Whitford if we could
terminate your presidency then I might
be known as The Terminator the
shermanator
that's a weird nickname to give yourself
I might be known as the terminated
now the crime in this case is
obstruction of justice fake nose it's
the illegal no way to use threats or
intimidation with the intent to thwart a
federal criminal investigation Oh big
deal
remember back in February no you had
dinner with James Comey oh god that guy
you told him to go easy on the Flynn let
it go that's a violation of law that you
tried to curtail that investigation how
does he know that all right because I
totally did it in May
you fired James Comey and then you said
did it to thwart the Russia
investigation oh yeah that's the thing I
said on TV in front of everybody
then you remember in July you're up
there with the New York Times no and you
threatened Muller with being fired if
you looked at your personal finances
that's three different threats that's
obstruction of justice
this guy's relentless he's like a
machine
mr. president look at the Watergate
example about a year after the cyber
Berg the burglary at Watergate was
discovered whoa wait a minute there was
a cyber burglary no the cyber burglary
happened in 2016
wait cyber burglary the the cyber
burglary sherminator sherminator
shermanator it all makes sense now are
you like a time cop
are you traveling through time and
teaching different presidents it
probably goes back a hundred years here
in the House of Representatives drag
Sherman time to picture a man who runs
for office at different times working
towards taking out presidents to affect
history
that's fairly silly I'm still working it
out mr. president before you came here I
was worried about our country now I'm
very very worried there is no fate but
what we make for ourselves which means I
have no choice but to send a super rich
robot version of myself back to 2017
it's my only chance of escaping my
impeachment by the shermanator